bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde dans neuf jours vous allez
devoir faire un choix et pour vous y
aider chaque soir dans cette émission un
grand débat sur un grand thème de
campagne ce soir l'immigration sujet de
clivage par excellence et sujet sur
lequel l'extrême droite veut imprimer sa
marque et ses mots grand remplacement
remis gratien quotas quelle est la
réalité des chiffres et qui propose quoi
dans cette campagne la guerre en ukraine
et l'accueil massif des réfugiés et est
en train de changer le regard des
français sur ce sujet la question de
notre grand débat dans un instant sur ce
plateau notre grand témoin est un visage
familier de cette émission il s'est
lancé dans une grande enquête au plus
près des français avec une idée très
stimulante suivre la ligne de
démarcation pour les rencontrer cette
frontière intérieure de plus de 1000 km
en 1940 il y a découvert une france qui
souffre mais moins diviser qu'il n'y
paraît richard wehrli est avec nous ce
soir enfin dans le scan ce soir l'oeil
de blacko ausculte cet écart qui se
resserre entre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron l'humour en politique ça existe
mais dans la campagne où est il ce sera
avec virginie ce pièce et puis un petit
nouveau brandon ouaret qui a regardé
pour nous tous les clips de campagne
voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs un grand débat donc
chaque soir sur un grand thème de
campagne pour vous aider à y voir plus
clair dans les programmes d'ici au 10
avril rendez vous compte c'est dans neuf
jours seulement et ce soir le thème sur
lequel rappelez-vous devait se jouer
cette élection l'immigration c'est ce
que disaient les sondages il ya un peu
plus d'un mois maintenant avant la
guerre en ukraine et la flambée des prix
des carburants et de l'énergie il
n'empêche ce sujet restent en assez
bonne place dans la préoccupation des
français on va en parler ce soit avec
vous béatrice giblin bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être là vous êtes géopolitologue
vous dirigez la revue hérodote vous
connaissez bien ces questions a liés à
l'émigration bonsoir jean sébastien
ferjou à vis de vous avoir sur le
plateau vous êtes le fondateur et le
directeur du site d'informations
atlantico et puis dans le fauteuil du
grand témoin ce soir richard richard
wehrli l'ami richard qui publie la
france contre elle même on vous
interrogera d'ailleurs sur ce titre qui
est assez fort c'est chez grasset de la
démarcation de 1940 aux fractures
d'aujourd'hui on en parle dans la
deuxième partie mais c'est intéressant
de savoir au fond ce que vous avez
recueilli du terrain sur ce thème aussi
de de l'immigration je précise que
françois gemenne qui est enseignant à
sciences po et à la sorbonne spécialiste
de ces questions de migration mais aussi
de gouvernance climatique va nous
rejoindre dans un instant je vous donne
la parole mais d'abord on va faire le
point sur les programmes c'est un tour
d'horizon signé alex clio sur
l'immigration
l'immigration il en a fait son cheval de
bataille dans cette campagne épousant et
revendiquant la thèse controversée du
grand remplacement jusqu'à vouloir créer
un ministère de l'armee gracieux son
programme est le plus radical objectif
zéro immigration je veux m'en prendre à
l'immigration légale arrêté le droit au
regroupement familial arrêté le droit
d'asile le réduire à quelques dizaines
voire quelques centaines de personnes je
veux réduire aussi drastiquement le
nombre d'étudiants étrangers la droite
partagent aujourd'hui des idées de
l'extrême droite s'ils sont élus eric
zemmour marine le pen et valérie
pécresse veulent réduire l'accès des
étrangers aux aides sociales obliger les
réfugiés à effectuer leur demande
d'asile depuis l'étranger et supprimer
le droit du sol naître en france ne
suffirait alors plus pour être français
autant de mesures qu'ils veulent tous
les trois soumettre à référendum mais la
candidate les républicains se distingue
sur un point elle veut faire voter
chaque année des quotas d'accueil par
métier et par pays
de son côté emmanuel macron durci le ton
il propose de limiter les voies de
recours aux expulsions dans son
programme également remettre à plat
schengen pour filtrer plus efficacement
l'immigration clandestine aux frontières
de l'europe à gauche aucune mesure sur
l'immigration illégale on préfère jouer
la carte de l'intégration plutôt que
celle de la répression et surtout sortir
de l'optique sécuritaire aujourd'hui
vous avez des responsables politiques y
compris qu'ils sont pas d'extrême droite
qui veulent organiser l'europe avec des
murs des barbelés des miradors pour se
protéger de qui
les verts voudrait confier la question
de l'immigration à un grand ministère
des solidarités et dans la france de
jean luc mélenchon de yannick jadot et
de fabien roussel il faudrait
régulariser tous les sans papiers qui
ont un enfant scolarisé en france où un
travail mais oui nous devons régulariser
parce qu'il en a assez de vivre dans la
peur dans l'angoissé et que c'est
insupportable
le chef des insoumis souhaiterait aussi
suspendre le règlement dublin renégocier
les accords du touquet et créer un
statut de détresse environnementale on
va revenir sur ces propositions béatrice
giblin mais d'abord sur au fond
l'inversion des préoccupations c'est
important tout de même le pouvoir
d'achat et crafton il ya un mois et demi
c'était pas le cas aujourd'hui
l'immigration vient après la sécurité en
cinquième position quand on regarde les
derniers sondages sur les attentes des
français qu'est-ce que ça traduit alors
bien sûr il ya la flambée des prix mais
est ce que ça veut dire que ça relève
encore du fantasme c'est bien trop naïf
de dire ça sur l'immigration aujourd'hui
l'immigration ne relève pas du fantasme
ce serait une erreur de le penser que ce
soit une question qui préoccupe un
certain nombre de français c'est
incontestable et puis ça s'explique il
ya certain nombre de faits réels à la
peine de faire semblant enfin ça je
pense que ça a été d'ailleurs sans doute
peut-être une erreur de la gauche c'est
ne pas avoir voulu regarder en face les
problèmes qui se posaient avec une
particularité vraiment qu'il y a en
france il ya eu une augmentation du
nombre des étrangers sur les 10 15
dernières années c'est incontestable que
c'est ce soit une immigration qui
viennent en fait de culture très
différente de la nôtre essentiellement
afrique du nord afrique subsaharienne si
on veut mais surtout c'est la
répartition géographique de cette
population étrangère qui fait qu' on a
des focus qui donne l'impression qu'il
ya une invasion par exemple la seine
saint denis et ses à-côtés deux pas de
paris
c'est 70% de la population qui est
d'origine immigrés avec des enfants de
proportion de moins de 25 ans très très
très importante et quand on met le
regard sur la seine saint denis qui est
très particulière c'est le lieu
d'arrivée des primo arrivants depuis
toujours parce que le marché du travail
de paris et evs est effectivement
extrêmement actif et seulement ce regard
là donne l'idée que c'est le tout donc
il ya une forme de bien aussi avec les
rejets un contexte tellement ils vendent
bien même si la répartition géographique
est très localisée et ça il faudrait
avoir le temps d'expliquer pourquoi
c'est comme ça en france c'est pas
pareil en angleterre c'est pas pareil en
c'est pas pareil non plus en espagne
pourquoi c'est comme ça on refroidit et
nous parce que c'est une question du
logement c'est une autre question de
logements qui explique ce genre de
choses on a concentré pourquoi on a
consacré parce que la guerre 14-18 c'est
qu'on bloque les loyers les
propriétaires ne construisent plus et on
maintient le blocage des loyers après
après la guerre chute démographique on
construit pas dans les années une 36 là
on se rend compte qu'on commence à
manquer d'eau chemin on va faire les
hbpm disons les ancêtres des hlm on se
met à construire de nouveau la guerre 39
reprises du baby boom avant même la fin
de la guerre et on se retrouve dans les
années 50 avec une pénurie de logements
et une perte de savoir faire qui est
très important nos fameux maçon du
limousin qui ne sont plus là pour savoir
compter la concrète et ma paye là et
aujourd'hui et quand est ce qu'on fait
une industrie du logement de façon
exceptionnelle les soviétiques vont
venir voir comment on fait en france
pour essayer de faire pareil chez eux
pour pouvoir loger beaucoup et là on va
faire des cités quand ce qu'on appelait
des cités pour pouvoir loger beaucoup
beaucoup de monde l'augmentation du
niveau de vie avec les femmes qui sont
mis à travailler tout tout tout les
trente glorieuses on quitte ces
logements qui étaient des lieux de
mixité sociale pour aller dans des
petits immeubles pour avoir des maisons
parce qu'on a une voiture tout ça change
et donc des six gagnants furent messali
homicide ces endroits mais surtout tout
ce qui était en bidonvilles on va les
loger là et c'est la mort si vous voulez
de cette concentration d'une population
d'origine immigrée qui ne restent pas il
ya une noria des gens sortent ils
s'intègrent ils veulent aussi un
pavillon ils veulent mais c'est sans
arrêt si vous voulez cette noria qui
serait alimenté et donc le regard sur
cette idée d'une invasion en france est
biaisé je crois par cette histoire
extrêmement particulière mais le
lancement français mais jean-sébastien
ferjou on pourrait se dire au fond s'il
ya un problème lié à l'immigration se
serait ce seront les habitants de ces
endroits là qui devrait le le manifester
et pas l'ensemble du pays or on se rend
bien compte même si effectivement la
préoccupation économique après le dessus
le pouvoir d'achat que la question elle
est nationale en tout cas en termes
d'attenté de et de préoccupation
pourquoi est ce que c'est parce que le
débat s'est totalement draps droitiser
faute de projet alternatif à gauche où
est ce que parce que voilà il ya une
peur réelle dans le pays
je crois que la question du nombre ou
des chiffres fini par produire des
effets fin et c'est surtout ça alors le
mot invasion enfin je comprends bien que
ce n'est pas celui que vous utilisez
je trouve que effectivement c'est un mot
qui à éviter absolument pas cela
supposerait qui n'est ce pas de projets
construits et puis qui est des gens qui
veulent vraiment mettre la main sur la
france après pour autant il ya une
réalité démographique qui a changé et
que effectivement on n'a pas assez voulu
voir et les démographes qui travaillent
sur le sujet la gauche dans une partie
de l'université française aussi michèle
tribalat explique très bien comment dans
l'université précisément ces questions
là on était bas et parce que la
sociologie poste années 60 en gros a
considéré que la vision politique devait
l'emporter sur la rigueur scientifique
mais les nombres sont là je veux dire il
suffit de prendre un simple indice à
regarder la population française en 1970
c'est à peu près le moment où le seuil
de renouvellement des générations ne se
fait plus la natalité fait qu'on passe
en dessous du seuil de renouvellement
des générations
il ya 15 millions de français en plus
aujourd'hui alors certes il ya des
effets qui sont liés à la mortalité à
l'élévation de l'âge la mortalité mais
vous voyez bien qu'ils sont pas apparus
par génération spontanée non plus et ce
n'est pas qu'en seine-saint-denis parce
qu'en seine-saint-denis évidemment c'est
plus marqué mais vous pouvez aller à
marseille vous pouvez aller à lyon et
vous pouvez mois de suppôt vinciane
aller dans beaucoup de petites villes où
vous voyez que le visage des petites
villes a changé et ça les français le
constat après ça ne serait pas un
problème en soi s'il n'y avait pas à
côté un problème d'intégration
il met aussi sur la spécificité de
l'immigration français parce que vous
posez la question du point de vue des
immigrés mais bien sûr qu'on peut
comprendre le sort de gens qui vivent
dans des espèces de ghettos qui serait
fondé à s'en plaindre mais il ya une
spécificité point de vue des français
qui habitent dans ces zones là non mais
bien sûr mais peu importe d'ailleurs
d'origine étrangère et emporte partout
ils sont là ils ont un droit légitime
participer à la vie du pays et à
considérer qu'il ya des frais mais vous
dit sello tissu c'était une spécificité
de l'immigration elle est plus familiale
elle est moins qualifiés qu'ailleurs et
ça ça produit aussi des effets parce que
vous avez d'autres d'autres pays vous
avez une immigration qui s'intègrent
mieux pour des histoires de langue pour
des yeux pour des raisons historiques en
france ce sont moins des immigrés
diplômés qui viennent et c'est beaucoup
une immigration familiale et c'est du
reste ce qu'ils vont sortir d'une étude
le cda qui a été publié alors quelques
chiffres à vous soumettre richard vers
les vous allez me dire si vous avez
retrouvé ça dans votre enquête de
terrain quand on saute les français sur
l'immigration ils sont 71% c'est ipsos
qui le montre à s'estimer inquiets pour
leur pays un peu moins 57% inquiets pour
eux-mêmes mais quand on va sur la
question de l'identité puisque c'est la
grande question d'eric zemmour alors là
il n'y a pas de réponse sur la crise de
l'identité en france sur l'immigration
au contraire quand on leur demande qui
menacent leur identité ils citent
l'affaiblissement économique la
désindustrialisation
et le chômage ça veut dire que la thèse
du grand remplacement n'est pas la bonne
quand on demande aux français attention
notre identité est menacée ils ne le
vois pas comme ça coûtait alors moi pour
le livre j'ai il ya d'une part ce que
j'ai fait pour le livre drôle parce que
je fais comme correspondant en france
depuis plusieurs années pour le livre
j'ai suivi un itinéraire bien
particulier vous l'avez dit que
l'itinéraire de la ligne de démarcation
qui traversait la france en plein milieu
c'est-à-dire dans des zones plus que
périphérique à venir des zones rurales
ce qu'on aurait pu appeler le socle de
la vieille france le socle de la france
du centre dans cette france rurale là
moi je n'ai quasiment jamais y compris
dans des agglomérations moyennes senti
que les gens avaient peur du grand
emplacement pour employer ce terme qui
est ma faim dans le débat public je ne
laisse jamais senti ce qui est vrai en
génération il était prononcée alors le
mot immigration il est prononcé
évidemment parce que quand vous parlez
de la situation de la france
d'aujourd'hui il vient dans la
conversation comme le chômage comme les
services publics mais on parle beaucoup
plus dans cette france là des déserts
médicaux que l axe d'après un sujet qui
traumatise les gens tu t'ouvres sa santé
retraites un des trois prix or était
selon la dernière enquête france info
qui change et là je ne sais pas si c'est
à ça que jean sébastien faisait
référence mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai
été frappée que quand vous êtes dans des
petites villes moyennes le soir sur la
place centrale la traditionnelle place
du village qui très souvent n'a pas
tellement changé de morphologie par
rapport à 1940 d'ailleurs vous regardez
les photos c'est la même chose là vous
voyez c'est vrai une population qui
n'est pas la population blanche
française classique pourquoi parce que
vous avez tous les livreurs divers et
variés qui sont là avec leurs mobylettes
vous avez les mamans qui sortent leurs
enfants et qui assez fréquemment
effectivement peuvent être des mamans
voilées donc il ya il ya eu un
changement ça c'est vrai je l' ai vu et
je peux comparer par exemple la suisse
il y a eu un changement de morphologie
sthers que vous voyez mais ça veut pas
dire pour autant que la population de
ces villages a changé mais il y a un
effet visuel qui à mon avis explique
pour beaucoup l'inquiétude d'autant que
cet été visuel il est décuplée par ce
que vous voyez sur les chaînes de
télévision mais très bien sur sept ce
couple immigration identité que fait
très clairement eric zemmour il se
trompe dans l'analyse par rapport aux
attentes j'en suis absolument persuadé
il se trompe complètement
profondément je pense que les français à
la fois ils sont sur une idée de déclin
ils ont peur du déclin de leur nation et
par ailleurs ils sont extrêmement fiers
d'être d'être français et un sentiment
d'appartenance à ce qui a été une grande
puissance qu'elle n'est plus bien
évidemment
il faut arrêter quand même de répéter
sans arrêt qu'il n'ya pas d'intégration
que cette intégration soit des moments
difficiles dans certains lieux et pour
certaines familles c'est incontestable
mais pour avoir enseigné pendant 30 ans
en seine-saint-denis hassen ni même pour
avoir une sous mes yeux un certain
nombre d'étudiants dont les parents
étaient analphabètes et eux se
trouvaient en master et dans un master
reconnu arrivant à faire des tests et
soins étant aujourd'hui journaliste à
l'os et 2 autre je crois qu'il faut
faire attention à ce discours de la
non-intégration elle est difficile mais
il faut voir jaillir l'extrême courage
volonté d'y arriver même si je ne suis
absolument pas naïf une partie de ces
enfants issus de l'immigration
décroche sont en grande difficulté sont
dans une délinquance
insupportable tout ça je veux bien
l'admettre alors mais pas sur l'or sur
la question de l'intégration ce sont des
français on précise les choses sur la
question de l'immigration les derniers
chiffres d'après les chiffres de 2010 9
parce que avec le co vide les choses
étaient biaisés deux cent soixante dix
sept mille entrées régulières
d'étrangers chaque année sur le
territoire ça se
répartit d'abord regroupement familial
30% étudiants étrangers 30% immigration
économique 14% sur les demandeurs
d'asile des chiffres varient c'est plus
compliqué mais on est autour de 10% ce
chiffre là il ya en gros toute la droite
qui veut le faire baisser valérie
pécresse dit on doit choisir pour le
résumer par quotas par métier par zone
géographique eric zemmour dit il faut le
ramener à 0
à votre avis qui dansaient dowling vous
semble plus crédible
mais ça ça chaque lecteur de se faire
une idée déjà 200 fonctions de c2c sous
zéro je pense qu'elle est factuellement
impossible parce que de toute façon il y
aura toujours une part de regroupement
familial
il y aura toujours une part d'étudiants
et au delà de ça nous avons besoin
d'étudiants étrangers le sujet est celui
à mon sens plutôt des échecs de
l'intégration
il est vraiment celui des échecs
pourquoi l écran
de l'intégration à raison pardon de dire
qu'elle est possible mais elle est quand
même de plus en plus difficile et au
delà ça n'est plus jugé comme
souhaitable par une partie des
populations d'origine étrangère en
france et c'est ça le projet fait débat
sur l'intégration alors je voulais en
parler à s'intégrer dans la campagne
qu'il un peu remplacé à droite et à
l'extrême droite c'est le mot
d'assimilation gros mots pas gros mots
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est
on peut avoir des débats l'infini sur la
simulation intégration enfin des débats
philosophiques sait pas exactement une
spécificité de l'immigration qui
arrivent en france c'est qu'il ya un
passé colonial il ya à la fois la
dimension ce sont des gens qui arrivent
plutôt de pays arabo musulmans et
l'islam est plus compliqué à intégrer
que d'autres cultures aujourd'hui
effectivement que ça ne l'a été dans le
passé parce que on a laissé un certain
nombre de pays l'islam d'aujourd'hui ces
deux d'islam et l'islam qui est présent
en france et de l'islam qu'on a laissé
être contrôlée par notamment des
idéologies venus des pays des pays de la
péninsule arabique ce n'est absolument
plus le même islam que celui qui
arrivait avec des marocains ou des
algériens il ya trente ans il ya 40 ans
est d'ailleurs les générations en
question ne reconnaissent plus l'islam
de leurs propres enfants et cet islam là
il est dans un projet politique et il
est dans un projet qui refuse la france
et qui de toute façon on refuse aussi
bien l'intégration que l'assimilation et
cela me parler de comment l'islam
et du point de vue des personnes les
musulmans ou de même titre que n'importe
qui d'autre sont parfaitement capables
et de s'intégrer et d'avoir la distance
par rapport à leur propre religion ou
leur propre froid personnes et
essentialiser au point où il serait
juste l'outil d'enfin l'instrument d'une
origine il ya un projet de l'islam
politique et qu'on ne peut pas ignorer
non mais la pression d'ignorer le projet
de l'islam politique c'est êtes-vous non
monsieur mélenchon c'est moins certain
énorme et je suis bien d'accord mais je
reviens sur pourquoi cet islam politique
peut-il prospérait dans certains lieux
est-ce qu'on est sur des phénomènes de
concentration quand vous prenez le
contrôle d'une cité ou même d'une partie
de citer à ce moment là le comportement
social du groupe et est très j'allais
dire imprimé par cet islam politique
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il ya une
stratégie
véritablement essentiel la france à
faire c'est de lutter contre les
phénomènes de consentement vous
expliquez que là on parle de la
politique de la ville en fait c'est de
la politique de la ville de
l'aménagement du territoire je posais la
question de comment comment au fait pour
intégrer si tout le monde est au même
endroit ça personne n'en parle dans la
campagne la question d'écarter la
question du logement elle est essentiel
d'aller contre toute la mais je suis
absolument d'accord avec vous on a
beaucoup travaillé dessus sur atlantico
on pourrait décliner quasiment toute une
campagne présidentielle tous les sujets
d'insécurité d'intégration même de santé
publique je vais vous dire sont à peu
près lié au choix d'urbanisme qu'on fait
d'énergie et c'est donc la question du
logement elle est absolument centrale
mais je crois pas que ce soit lié
uniquement au phénomène de concentration
c'est au lit c'est aussi lié à une perte
d'identité c'est à dire que pourquoi
est-ce que la limite peu importe que ce
soit l'islam politique ou tout autre
idéologie il y à une perte une
fragmentation de l'identité française et
c'est ça qui fait que c'est comme un gaz
qui emplit le vide est depuis ce que
l'oeil
drysdale est la conséquence est
construit en quelque sorte les
appartenances traditionnel c'est qu'on a
déconstruit la famille on a déconstruit
l'autorité on a déconstruit les cultures
régionales on a déconstruit beaucoup
donné figurez vous le honda des
consciences est ce de manière générale
ou l'intelligencia de gauche
universitaires notamment avec notamment
la grande théorie la déconstruction mais
une fois que vous avez déconstruit tout
ça il est très difficile de donner une
chance du sens à la vie
sauf que justement il ya des idéologies
qui l on donne alors
au milieu d'autres époques ça pouvait
être d'autres idéologies ans a pu être
le marxisme qui donne de l'espoir aux
gens il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui l'islam
et l'histoire un cadre de vie le lever
au coucher de sens que la société
française elle n'arrive plus à
véritablement offrir réservé les là
dessus moi j'ai quand même un problème à
ramener et c'est un peu ce qu'on est en
train de faire là le sujet de
l'immigration à l'islam parce que je
pense que le sujet de l'immigration
c'est l'immigration se dire comment on
fait pour intégrer une population il
faudrait quand même rajouter aux
chiffres que vous avez donnée myriam les
clandestins parce que là ce sont les
chiffres officiels oui elle est
clandestin c'est toujours compliqué
d'avoir des chiffres en année avant le
sujet de l'immigration est un sujet
essentiel je dirais social et
réglementaire c'est à dire à quoi ont
droit les immigrés qui arrivent en
france et puis il ya le sujet politique
de l'islam externe moi j'ai un peu de
peine à lier systématiquement les deux
une observation quand même au cours de
ce voyage que j'ai fait et il se trouve
que là aujourd'hui je reviens de suisse
il ya une chose qui étonne vu de
l'étranger en france il faut bien le
dire c'est l'automaticité des aides
sociales c'est à dire que le fait que
vous mettiez le pied en france vous
donne droit à des prestations sociales
qui ne sont pas rien surtout quand il
s'agit de soins hospitaliers
ça c'est une spécificité française qui
franchement interroge un peu près tout
le monde en europe c'est bien d'être il
faut peut-être se poser cette question
je ne prétends pas y répondre mais est
ce qu'il y à lacq c'est clairement
quelque chose avec lequel les français
que j'ai rencontrés dans cette partie du
pays où un problème alors là tous les
candidats de droite propose soit de
supprimer soit de conditionner les aides
sociales non contributives messages
codés tranché je pense que c'est une
vraie question et elle est importante je
crois qu'il n'y a pas plus généreux que
la france mais si on compare avec les
autres pays européens dans les
conditions d'accueil dans les prises en
charges dette sociale dans j'ai à dire
les revenus converse l'hébergement qui
peut être sans limite de temps même si
on a toujours des associations qui
trouve que c'est pas assez la france est
extrêmement généreuse avec les
l'accueil des étrangers il faut le dire
et est vraiment la voir les reportages
d'ailleurs je l'affirmé lanestérienne
dans un antre est très important alors
on peut s'en glorifier on peut aussi
comprendre que pour une partie des
français qui pour lequel tout c'est à
dire ceux cette générosité et le
résultat de combats est le résultat de
luttes est le résultat d'une longue
histoire de conquêtes sociales de
contrat et il pouvoir se dire bah voilà
alors eux ils arrivent et ils ont tout
tout de suite et puis et puis peut-être
qu'ils sont tellement nombreux que du
coup on va pas pouvoir nous les garder
alors ça c'est très clair peut-être
parce que dans un certain nombre de dans
un certain nombre d'endroits le lien
entre déserts médicaux d'un côté et de
l'autre accès aux soins pour les
populations immigrés notamment les
métropoles pose problème précis mais
même s'il n'a aucun lien il fallait
quand même
y a pas de lien mécanique entre vient
rien par celui du budget de l'état n'y a
pas d'intention c'est pour essayer de se
repérer à béatrice giblin sur les sur
les programmes chacun qui nous regardent
fera un peu son tri voilà on a compris
sur la question des aides sociales c'est
intéressant est sûre au fond ces grandes
conquêtes ce pacte national sur la
tolérance zéro sur l'immigration zéro
vous disiez c'est impossible total
claquant même des candidats qui vous
disent ils jouent sur un ménage d'erreur
c'est ce qu'ils disent mais je serai
bien une erreur enfin je veux dire si la
france n'a qui n'accueille plus
d'étudiants étrangers pour venir se
former qui seront l'élite de leur propre
pays mais ça veut dire que c'est un
recul d'une présence française dans les
contacts culturels économiques et même
politiques qui est absolument un retour
à un bon pourrait par référendum au fond
est supprimé le regroupement familial
la suisse l'a fait et est supprimé
l'émigration économique même s'il ya des
pénuries et on voit dans le recrutement
faire par référendum et il est possible
que sous des formes comment la question
est posée quelle compagnie fait mais il
est possible que vous obteniez un oui
pour ce genre de choses c'est pour ça
que moi je me suis toujours très
prudente avec les référendum il faut
être sûr de la réponse qu'on veut et on
disait tout à l'heure que en matière
d'immigration la france s'est suicidé on
sait que la suisse leur histoire au
secours du haut niveau du débat public
incontestablement la suisse c'est d'une
évidence n'est pas un pays très généreux
en matière d'immigration même s'il y a
des études des étudiants étrangers même
si les universités suisses accueil
énormément d'univers du d'étudiants
étrangers enfin pas trop maghrébins
quand même non je suis pas tout à fait
là bas c'est cher alors oui parce que le
système n'est pas le même le système est
différent la différence est là ce que je
voulais ce que je voulais dire c'est
'qui les thématiques vous savez en
suisse il ya une réalité parlementaire
il y à 30% des voix est en gros 30 % des
élus du parlement qui depuis vingt ans
sont d'extrême droite donc à peinture
donc ces thématiques ont été
naturellement portés par ce parti qui
s'appelle udc et ses thématiques se sont
installés dans le débat public avec
notamment des consultations l'absolument
en kayak des consultations alors
il y à une autre question posée par le
référendum et le recours au référendum
c'est béatrice ont imposé une partie il
y en a une autre c'est comment vous
faites pour mettre en oeuvre la décision
du référendum exclu comment vous faites
pour renvoyer ces gens qui boudent les
ont renvoyés quand on sait déjà que les
allégations
moi j'en ai terriblement un petit mot
que je vous montre le sujet sur les dix
rats les blattes rona si vous lui
enlevez d'un seul coup toute cette main
d'oeuvre dont il a besoin jean sébastien
ferjou
ni souhaitable ni possible en revanche
écouter la demande des français ça ça
doit être fait et c est parfaitement
légitime dans le cadre d'une démocratie
sinon des sites qu'on décida le plat des
français y compris d'ailleurs parce qu'
il faudrait pas qu'ils se prononcent par
référendum des facs y donnant une
réponse qui ne correspondrait pas à
celles qu'on souhaite mais au delà ça il
ya des affichages d'objectifs qui sont
eux-mêmes performatif regardez ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis aux états
unis on vient les statistiques viennent
de sortir c'est moins 75% d'immigration
depuis 2016 depuis le mur
qui a marché c'est pas le mur c'est le
fait que les gens notamment en amérique
du sud ont compris que les états unis
n'étaient plus un pays accueillant le
sujet de la france et qu'il paraît
encore à lorient et qu'il part accueilli
à des propositions notamment sur
mes juges avoir été berné c'est à dire
que il ya je regardais sur un ton aussi
un autre classement qui a été fait qui a
été fait le les états unis ne sont plus
le pays qui attire le plus les talons
ben non c'est maintenant le canada mais
dans le même temps alors même si on a
élu on appelle lui 2003 pour n'a pas
voté pour le brix it on et la start up
née shon mais la france est beaucoup
descendus dans le classement des pays
les plus attractifs pour les talents
c'est bien ça notre sujet c'est que nous
continuons à être relativement attractif
par le biais des allocations sociales
font des prestations de la générosité
français sur une partie de son choix au
fond des migrations à la fois
intégrés et qui par ailleurs est celle
qui peut-être un peu plus les français
qui eux par ailleurs manque à la prouve
que l'état investit pas assez avec eux
et on ne sait pas assez gérer
l'immigration de talent ou l'immigration
économique parce que le patronat il ne
trouve pas dans l'immigration qui
arrivent en france dont il a besoin je
voudrais avoir un point de vue de très
cynique devrait vous montrer pour
terminer ce débat un sujet sur les
réfugiés on a l'impression que le regard
change depuis l'accueil massif des
réfugiés ukrainien peut-être aussi sur
le thème de l'immigration on verra les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
c'est d'une crise qui s'est rendu à luzy
dans la nièvre où la municipalité
accueille des familles syriennes
reportage et puis un petit mot pour
réagir juste après
l'usi sa campagne bourguignonne
sa barre hlm où cohabitent des habitants
landa et 60 demandeurs d'asile soixante
personnes qui attendent la réponse de
l'ofpra l'office français de protection
des réfugiés
pour être autorisé à rester dans notre
pays des hommes seuls et des familles
taman ici depuis un an et demi vient
d'avoir une réponse favorable la fin
d'un long parcours débuté un rack à en
syrie on voit trop
ça au fait c'est un
hamster 100 m elle s'est laissé les
sauces aux bombes avions etc
aftergood tel quel mais causant brad
pitt
son fils aîné va à l'école du village
dans une classe de cp avec des petits
français il apprend à lire en même temps
que notre longue
avec son statut de réfugié taman va être
autorisée à chercher du travail mais il
va aussi devoir quitter cet appartement
qui n'est qu'une structure provisoire un
regret pour sa voisine
ça va
remuer les escaliers
les demandeurs d'asile sont logés ici
gratuitement
[Musique]
en plus pour se nourrir se vêtir se
déplacer une personne seule touche 204
euros par mois une famille de 4 510
euros
mais moins d'un tiers d'entre eux aura
finalement le statut de réfugié la
grande majorité sera reconduit à la
frontière où vivre à une existence de
son papier actuellement on a beaucoup de
ressortissants afghans qui nous des
rejets de demander ce qu'il n'y avait
pas il ya quelques mois parce que pour
les autorités françaises le fait que les
talibans ont repris le pouvoir stabilise
et minimise les risques de persécution
pour beaucoup de sorties sans fin
la france compte actuellement 112 mille
places pour demandeurs d'asile
moitié moins que le nombre nécessaire
malgré la demande d'asile qui est plus
importante que les places offertes dans
notre pays c'est un exemple et bien que
les municipalités safer g et qu'il n'y a
pas forcément de face à face et là il
s'agissait de deux familles syriennes
parce que vous gérez des effectifs petit
le problème c'est quand vous avez à
gérer beaucoup beaucoup de monde je
reviens sur mon exemple de la seine
saint denis honnêtement pour le
département de la seine saint denis ou
pour la mairie de saint-denis ou de la
courneuve c'est ingérable c'est
extrêmement difficile on a fait faire
une étude justement sur ces réfugiés où
l'arrivée d'étrangers au sein de
l'occitanie en regardant les villes où
vous savez et émile wauquiez avait dit
on va créer décalé vous savez quand on a
supprimé la jungle on va faire décaler
sur toute la france on n'a pas fait
décaler sur toute la france quand vous
mettez un petit nombre de gens à ce
moment là la population va se mobiliser
même ceux qui étaient contre qui se rend
compte que au fond ça se passe pas si
mal pour terminer ce débat jean
sébastien ferjou on n'a pas parlé des
réfugiés eux craignent un mais on voit
les lans solidarité dans le pays jusqu'à
100000 seront accueillis est ce que vous
pensez et la scène journée ce politique
et je m'adresse que ça peut changer la
donne est ce que est ce qu'il ya un
effet aussi guerre en ukraine accueil
des réfugiés sur ces thèmes qu'on dit
explosive de l'immigration en france je
pense pas que ceux perçus par le biais
de l'immigration parce que c'est perçu
comme les gens qui fuient un conflit qui
ne durait pas forcément très longtemps
et pas forcément que maison qui viennent
s'installer en france si la question
s'imposer comme quelque chose de durable
et des populations qui s'installe
durablement ça changera certainement
réaction sera différée perception
politique non je pense que le conflit en
lui-même qui modifie la campagne pour
des tas de raisons différentes parce
qu'on le voit sur les questions
d'énergie on le voit sur les questions
d'europe on le voit sur les questions de
défense européenne on voit que l'europe
s'était enfermé dans une espèce de
naïveté qui consistait à croire qu'on
était protégé tout est sorti l'histoire
non ça n'était pas le cas de toute façon
avant et ça n'est pas aujourd'hui et
c'est là aussi où on voit des candidats
qui peut-être pour certains c'était très
idéologues et avait quand même des
tentations il mais on dire pour des
régimes qui était déjà autoritaire avant
qui maintenant sont seulement
autoritaire son meurtrier merci beaucoup
en tout cas j'espère que ça ça vous a
aidé d'une certaine façon à faire à
faire votre choix en tout cas sur ce
thème là on a essayé d'être le plus
complet possible merci à vous vous
restez avec moi richard on va parler à
présent de votre livre la france contre
elle même chez grasset et cette idée
passionnant de suivre cette ligne de
démarcation de 1940 pour sculpter de
plus près les fractures françaises alors
qu'avez vous découvert vous le
journaliste suisse si francophile alors
d'ailleurs du retour de la guerre en
europe parce que tout ça se perd se
percutent vous allez nous dire juste
après le si on vous invite signé marc
opposé ce soir
si on vous invite richard vers l'iss et
parce que nous avons besoin de votre
éclairage sur l'état du pays hindi la
france archi pelli s'est fracturé
fracturé que les candidats à la
magistrature suprême auront bien du mal
à réparer la france est trop fracturé
elle est trop en colère ya trop de
mépris le pays est déjà un archipel de
communauté
malgré tout la république tient bon elle
tient debout grâce à vous jamais je ne
me résoudrai à ce que la france la
nation
se réduisent à un archipel richard
wehrli vous êtes le fils unique d'un
couple franco-suisse aujourd'hui
journaliste et correspondant à paris
pour le quotidien le temps un journal
référence en suisse avec votre regard
des lgv est la neutralité chevillée au
corps vous êtes un observateur avisé de
la france amusé par ces subtilités ses
contradictions aussi votre adn c'est le
journalisme de terrain souvent citée en
référence par la presse française vos
articles vos chroniques sont appréciés
on retiendra votre coup de gueule sur
lcp forcément sur la politique spectacle
royaume france mais c'est vrai que je
commence à en avoir assez pour ne pas
dire plus parce que nous sommes à cinq
mois de l'élection présidentielle
et c'est l'industrie du commentaire
politique qui me fatigue dans votre
dernier livre richard wehrli vous
décrivez une france empêché d'être elle
même une france qui s'épuise dans ses
querelles internes mais capable de
résilience de sursaut face aux séismes
de l'histoire un constat nourri par
votre voyage dans les bourgs les
villages sur la ligne de démarcation
celle qui séparait autrefois la zone
libre et la zone occupée par l'allemagne
une ligne tout au long de laquelle se
trouve aujourd'hui une france du vide et
des colères d'après vous c'est une
france dont on parle peu il me semblait
cantiran ce fils de la ligne de
démarcation j'allais peut-être
rencontrer l'âme française l'âme de la
france d'hier qui aujourd'hui est
souvent celles qui souffrent et souvent
celle qui a de la peine à se reconnaître
dans la modernité une france plongée
dans une colère sourde que vous avez
rencontré vu interroger car quand les
petits commerces ferment quand les
médecins se font rares que les fins de
mois inquiète et que les trains se font
attendre pour reprendre votre constat
comment ne pas tomber dans la défiance
alors richard wehrli vous qui êtes
persuadé que les fractures d'aujourd'hui
peuvent être surmontées à l'image des
démarcations d'hier une question ce soir
à vous dieu quel est le meilleur
candidat de cette présidentielle pour
réparer cette france capot c à vous la
parole
allez je la poserai à la fin je sens que
vous allez esquivé riches à cette
dernière question reprenons depuis le
début cette idée d'où elle vient
précisément de suivre de retourner sur
cette ligne de démarcation pour
ausculter la france s est fracturé
d'aujourd'hui alors elles viennent deux
choses d'abord politiquement elle vient
d'eric zemmour qui en 2018 intervient
genève pour présenter son livre le
suicide français vous souvenez ce
best-seller jeu l'interview pour le
temps et tout l'entretien est axée sur
le thème de la disparition de la france
qui lui est cher il dit la france peut
disparaître les français ont peur
qu'elle disparaisse et là je m'interroge
je me dis et si c'était vrai et s'il
était vrai que la france pouvait
disparaître donc quel analogies
historiques on peut trouver l'analogie
historique c'est 1940 parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu d'autres moments dans l'histoire
contemporaine où la france a été autant
menacée de disparition tout était en
place donc à l'addition à l'aise et ça
n'a pas été le cas et c'est ce que je
raconte dans le livre est aussi une
petite raison personnelle une petite
raison personnelle parce qu'il se trouve
que j'ai grandi en france et que ma mère
et j'ai grandi dans un village qui est
juste à la limite de la zone sera sur la
ligne de démarcation puisqu'il est dans
le sud de la nièvre à un endroit où
l'allier forme et la ligne de
démarcation puisque cette ligne qui a
été instaurée par les allemands donc
lors de l'armistice de juin 40 elle
était à la fois composé de route de
rivière et quelquefois les traverser des
champs et des forêts mais plus rarement
l on va regarder cette cette carte un
instant de la ligne de démarcation qui
coupait le pays en deux ans en 1940 en
fait on découvre qu'elle est beaucoup
plus longue et sinueuse
c'est pas simplement une ligne droite au
milieu de la france qui la découpe en
deux du nord au sud 1200 km de
frontières intérieures vous avez au fond
suivi cette ligne combien de communes
visitées combien de régions départements
alors les départements il y en a 13 qui
étaient traversés par cette ligne de
démarcation les régions il y en a 5 et
les communes j'en ai visité je me suis
arrêté disons dans un peu près cent
vingt-cinq communes alors qu'ils avaient
vous voulu rencontrer en priorité alors
en priorité au début je voulais
rencontrer des survivants et je me suis
très vite aperçu que pour des raisons
d'âge manifeste ça devenait très
compliqué donc j'ai dû voir des
survivants je me suis surtout intéressé
à ceux qui les ont écoutés parce que on
découvre dans cette france là quantité
de petits musées
musée de la résistance la plupart du
temps où sont stockés les entretiens
avec les survivants donc on retrouve
beaucoup de matériel documentaire il y à
un centre d'interprétation d'ailleurs de
la ligne de démarcation à jeunes l'art
en saône-et-loire et ensuite je voulais
surtout rencontrer les maires les élus
locaux de ces zones pour comprendre en
quoi d'abord premièrement en quoi cette
fracture historique est encore présente
est-ce qu'elle les mémoires
et surtout quels sont les blessures
d'aujourd'hui alors justement annoncer
cette france de la démarcation france re
rahal écrivez vos paysanne agricole
besogneuse éloignés des centres de
décisions qu'est ce que vous retenez en
quelques mots de tous ces témoignages qu
avez-vous compris de ses fractures
françaises d'aujourd'hui d'abord il ya
une réponse simple à cette menace de la
disparition qui parait-il planerait sur
la france prenez comme je lé fais des
cartes postales ou des photos de 1942 la
ligne de démarcation
suivez la halle et dans un certain
nombre de villes et de villages et vous
verrez que la france n'a pas changé et
ça c'est assez stupéfiant de voir que
les mêmes pont l'endroit où il y avait
les guérites allemande et de l'autre
côté la police française ils sont
toujours là vous dites qu'en 1940 ce qui
est l immobilisme l'enracinement du pays
a permis au fond le sursaut a permis de
repousser les murs vous dit
qu'aujourd'hui cet immobilisme là cet
enracinement là se retourne contre ses
habitants là alors absolument sûr que je
me suis aussi inspiré d'un livre dont on
pourra reparler écrit par un
correspondant suis donc un prédécesseur
lointain après la seconde guerre
mondiale qui s'appelait herberth lüthi
et qui a fait un très beau livre qui
s'appelle à l'heure de son clocher
préfacé par vais regarder c'est lui
voilà exactement par ailleurs grand
historien qui avait travaillé sur
l'histoire de la banque protestante pour
répondre à votre question ce qui est
frappant c'est qu'effectivement à cette
époque et jusqu'à je dirais peut-être
aux années 80 même aux années 90 cette
france-là la france du centre la france
rurale que j'appelle la france immobile
non pas parce qu'elle ne bouge pas à
simplement parce que le bâti les
constructions sont toujours les mêmes
elle est le socle du pays et elle se
sent investi de ce rôle de socle
malheureusement aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle est pour partie la france du
grand déclassement tu as lire les
déserts médicaux dont on parlait tout à
l'heure les problèmes d'accès aux
services publics
et puis la difficulté de prendre sa
voiture en permanence pour tous quand le
prix de l'énergie augmentent on en a
parlé beaucoup avec les gilet jaune
quand ce socle est fragilisé c'est tout
le pays qui est fragilisé et c'est ça
qui m'inquiète c'est que cette france là
c'était au fond cette france sur
laquelle s'appuyait la république
maintenant c'est plus compliqué parce
que le socle il est fissuré alors
pourtant vous dit quand même que ce qui
nous divise et moins important que ce
qui nous relie vous dites que cette
mémoire là elle est encore vivace et
elle témoigne d'une forte appartenance à
la communauté nationale même quand on
vivait du du mauvais côté de cette ligne
de démarcation et vous dites certes aidé
fracture culturelle mais elles sont
principalement social et économique et
vous battez un peu en brèche la thèse de
jérôme fourquet sur l'archipel français
où ce serait là la question identitaire
qui serait la plus pertinente pour
comprendre le pays oui alors jérôme
fourquet je me souviens d'ailleurs une
fois j'étais avec lui sur le plateau
quand vous l'aviez invité pour parler de
l'archipel français de son autre livre
la france sous nos yeux qui sont des
livres absolument incontournable pour
comprendre la france d'aujourd'hui
effectivement moi je pense que dans
l'archipel français tout la description
est juste mais il manque une chose c'est
qu'il y à des passerelles sur toutes les
îles qui relie toutes les îles de cet
archipel et ses passerelles ce sont des
passerelles solides et pourquoi je fais
référence à la ligne de démarcation
parce que qu'est ce qui se passe en 1940
le pays est divisé de la pire des
manières puisque c'est l'occupant nazi
qui contrôlent le nord et la france de
pétain inféodés qui contrôle le sud est
bien se met en place toute une
organisation de français qui vont tout
faire pour faire passer cette ligne de
démarcation et pour moi c'est
extrêmement symbolique l'énergie que les
français vont déployer pour que puisse
passer des juifs en fuite évidemment
pour que puisse passer des prisonniers
de guerre pour que puisse passer des des
commandes aux anglais et aux
britanniques ou autre par contre il est
évident et il faudrait surtout pas
croire que dans ce livre je cherche à
oublier où j'oublie la proportion
affreuse de qui lie à vue en
france à cette époque là est ce que la
proportion de salo en france étaient
différentes de celles dans les autres
pays je crois pas je crois qu'il y a eu
effectivement des atrocités qui ont été
commises à l'ombre de cette de cette
ligne de démarcation mais franchement
quand vous interrogez les survivants que
j'ai vu ils se souviennent toujours de
cette période comme une période d'espoir
les choses étaient possibles malgré les
horreurs les choses étaient possibles
aujourd'hui vous faites le même
itinéraire beaucoup de gens vous disent
que les choses sont devenues impossibles
c'est ça la france contre elle-même pour
évoquer le titre le titre est emprunté
au titre anglais 2 ii du livre de ce
journaliste suisse fraenzi guenter self
c'était dans les années 50 c'est
exactement ça tire quand vous avez une
partie du pays aussi central que cette
partie là qui doute d'elle-même parce
qu'elle est sans arrêt en butte à des
batailles internes et qu'elle pense que
les choses sont devenues impossibles et
non plus possible il y a quand même
matière à s'inquiéter merci beaucoup
richard vers les éditions grasset la
france contre elle-même de la
démarcation de 1940 aux fractures
d'aujourd'hui c'est passionnant courez
courez dans votre librairie allez vous
rester avec moi on continue à parler de
la campagne présidentielle c'est le scam
vous connaissez désormais c'est parti
[Musique]
mais avant d'être il y a les deux pas de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
moi je vous propose le round mort d'agir
pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
vous exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur d'arriver à cela pas de mystère
c'est le vol
et bienvenue vous ces sportifs dans ça
vous regarde c'est une émission duré
trois chroniqueurs bonsoir stefan
bekowsky ravi de vous retrouver l'oeil
de blacko dans un instant toujours pour
démarrer ce scam fichiers virginis pièce
bonsoir on va parler de l'humour dans
cette campagne moi j'en ai pas vraiment
bougé beaucoup vous nous direz où il se
cache et un petit nouveau bonsoir
brandon ouaret vous avez regardé pour
nous est journaliste politique d'aller
regarder pour nous toutes les affiches
tous les clips pardonnez moi tous les
clips de campagne j'en ai raté plein ça
tombe bien ça va m'intéresser on
commence avec vous stéphane qu'est ce
qui attire et votre oeil aujourd'hui eh
ben vous regardez myriam regarder ce qui
attirait mon noël ce matin je disais la
presse et c'est la même expression qui
revient dans tous les journaux l'écart
se resserre entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron
bah oui vous souhaitez savoir jusqu'à
quel point alors quel point je sais mais
vous allez me dire alors dites moi
jusqu'à quel point
47,5
52,5
donne l'écart le plus serré entre les
deux n'a jamais été aussi serrée entre
les deux candidats et en plus c'est là
précise qu' il ya une marge d'erreur sur
ce sondage et cette marge d'erreur est
de 3,5 donc on ajoute 3,5 au 47,5 de
marine le pen et puisque vous êtes vous
spécialiser sondages voyant arriver à
51% donc marine le pen pour être la
première femme présidente de la
république d'ailleurs philippe
s'inquiète lui aussi à cette perspective
dit oui regardez bien sûr qu'elle peut
gagner marine le pen l'a vraiment une
chance d'y arriver alors dites nous
ce qu'il faut retenir donc nul à la mac
rooney je comprend bien qu'ils se
précipitent un petit peu dans l'arène
maintenant parce que bon
forcément au début quand on parlait de
l'ukraine s'est elle risque de guerre
mondiale donc c'était plus favorable à
maquereau le chef des armées se
resserrer autour de lui maintenant quand
on parle de l'ukraine c'est plutôt les
inquiétudes sur le pouvoir d'achat et
donc ça c'est plutôt le thème de marine
le pen young du coup il est descendu
dans la reynière macron donc très
combatif question de faire
un plaisir de les voir ou l'entendre de
démolir marine le pen en imaginant ce
qui serait arrivé si elle avait été élue
en 2017 si l'extrême droite il ya cinq
ans avait gagné vous n'auriez pas eu ce
vaccin parce qu'on serait sortie de
l'europe et la france n'a pas produit de
vaccins si l'extrême droite il ya cinq
ans avait gagné vous aurez peut-être une
d'hydroxyde chloroquine puisque
c'étaient les convictions du moment si
l'extrême droite ya cinq ans avait gagné
et bien vous auriez été vaccinées en
décembre et des vaccinés en janvier
parce que c'était les convictions c'est
ça la réalité faut aussi le dire le
costume du candidat il est le ring à 20
ans il était temps parce que seraient
tous les sondages le donnent gagnant
mais quand on regarde dans le détail des
chiffres un peu inquiétant par exemple
quand on en offrant sait quel est le
candidat auquel vous aimeriez barrer la
route à l'elysée si vous pouviez le
faire par votre vote et bien qu'ils
arrivent en tête emmanuel macron donc
est un phénomène de rejet
autour de lui et puis attention parce
que marine le pen et risque d'être un
peu plus coriace que en 2017 hier elle
était sur france 3 sur france 2 et donc
elle a répondu à l'attack de macron vous
allez voir que elle est un peu plus
rodés qu'en 2017 n'a ni queue ni tête
d'abord si la france n'a pas être vaccin
c'est à cause de lui pardon c'est parce
que les investissements dans la
recherche n'ont pas été fait parce que
la grande bretagne qui n'étaient pas
dans l'union européenne avec son vaccin
elle tout cela n'a ni queue ni tête
cantal à des vaccinations jeu un jour
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler avec
lui ce que je ne sais pas à quoi ça
correspond
bel marine le pen souriante calme
tranquille comme disait mitterrand je
sais pas si ce que je veux dire
inquiète un petit peu notre grand
quotidien du soir préféré kiki real a
remis à un signal de larmes hier soir
disant attention marine le pen peut-être
moins extrêmes par rapport à zemmour
mais elle reste distille une candidate
d'extrême droite donc le duel s'annonce
extrêmement serrée est pas là non plus
mais c'est moi je suis un petit peu
monter la sauce avec des chroniqueurs je
dirais qu'il arrive quelque chose mais
quand on regarde les possibilités de
guerre de victoire de marine le pen
c'est un sur dix jeux les parieurs c'est
une chance sur dix de l'emporter enfin
non plus énorme mais on pourrait aussi
imaginer que mon tour laisse une place à
mélenchon c'est une possibilité et ça
serait en tout cas un débat assez
différent de celui qui opposerait le pen
a mac ronde écoute adrien catelet
si le second tour est un duel entre
emmanuel macron et jean luc mélenchon
alors non seulement on aura un immense
événement pas le débat piteux de la
dernière fois et un débat sur les vraies
préoccupations des français l'élection
va à ce moment-là avoir un caractère de
référendum sociale voilà la semaine
prochaine on saura enfin qui sont les
cas difficiles dans un jour rendez vous
compte neuf jours seulement richard ça
vous étonne pas un petit peu franchement
que cette dynamique marine le pen soit
si forte que le car l'écart se resserre
que rien ne soit joué après ce qu'on a
appelé l'effet drapeau la gare en
ukraine le chef de guerre non parce que
je pense que d'abord elle a l'expérience
et quand on a l'expérience on peut
apprendre de ses erreurs passées c'est
ce qu'elle fait donc là il n'y a rien
d'autre à faire que de la féliciter en
tant que candidate elle a tiré les
bonnes leçons elle profite
incontestablement de le des difficultés
d'eric zemmour qui pâtit beaucoup plus
qu'elle de la guerre en ukraine compte
tenu de ses déclarations par contre je
trouve qu adrien 87,1 pas tort un débat
mélenchon sa supposée qu'ils se
qualifient pur mélenchon macron au
deuxième tour peut-être fournirait plus
une opposition de deux vrais modèles
politiques pour la france et permettrait
je dirais ce débat serait peut-être plus
satisfaisant compte tenu de tout ce que
les français voulaient pas la même
affiche ou non plus hein comme beaucoup
de français quand qu'en 2017 brandon
alors on va on va regarder avec vous les
clips de campagne il faut expliquer que
depuis la stricte égalité de temps de
parole d'un des derniers ça y est les
candidats font ce qu'on appelle des
clips officiels de campagne et tapas sur
toutes les chaînes parfois plusieurs
clips les uns après les autres alors
qu'est ce que ça donne alors j'ai
remarqué qu'il y avait deux façon de
s'adresser aux électeurs dans un premier
temps la façon conventionnelle et la
présentation plus personnelle et je me
suis focalisé sur les candidats qui joue
justement la carte de l'intimité alors à
commencer par jean luc mélenchon qui a
choisi sa bibliothèque pour nous
accueillir et parler de lui tel un
françois mitterrand qui nous accueille
pour son cliché officiel de président
alors la bibliothèque ici elle permet
forcément aux candidats d' afficher
autant d'idées qu'il n'ya de livres
visible et on en compte beaucoup c'est à
l'image de 694 idée
alors dans son clip mélenchon lui il
parle sur un ton très calme très posé
notamment lorsqu'il évoque une photo on
va l'avoir il dit on y voit tout ce qui
compte encore maintenant pour moi va
regarder ces images on voit un ouvrier
en train d'accrocher un drapeau français
face à la tour eiffel voilà c'est une
image forcément qui évoque le rêve de
mélenchon qui se voit déjà en haut de la
fiche à l'elysée forcément avec ce cadre
aux allures de révolution française et y
en a un autre candidat qui lui est plus
intimiste encore plus et ça c'est
particulier son son clip c'est yannick
jadot qui retourne en france avec un
clip aux allures de vieux téléfilm de
louis la brocante à un clip qui
forcément est très particulier puisqu'il
ya une l'omniprésence de la nature du
verre partout un yannick jadot filmé sur
tous les plans une terre natale qui est
pour lui je cite la construction de son
cheminement écologique c'est ce qu'il
affirme là en regardant vers l'horizon
avec le cliché qui exagéraient jusqu'au
bout en font les éoliennes pour
forcément dire que c'est un clip de
candidat écolo toujours un petit côté
kitsch dans ses clips c'est marre d'être
ultra ultra moderne vous avez regardé
celui de marine le pen marine le pen oui
vous allez voir il est trés il est très
particulier aussi puisque dès le départ
et pose un dilemme aux français pour
elle les français ont seulement deux
possibilités je cite poursuivre le
projet de déconstruction et de
fracturation des manuels macron ou
engager le sursaut autour de la nation
mais dans son clip c'est ça la chose la
plus importante aussi c'est qu'elle elle
veut montrer une autre image d'elle-même
on se focalise plus sur la marine le pen
en tant que femme en l'humanise ans
maximum c'est cette image qu'elle
travaille déjà depuis plusieurs années
elle cherche à inspirer confiance on la
voit poser voilà ces images là posé aux
côtés des français aux côtés des animaux
et aussi à ça c'est l'image qui m'a un
peu marqué ce côté d'un enfant on la
présente comme un peu la petite mer des
peuples en donnant une autre image
d'elle-même à deux chats dans le clip
non pas de chars cette fois ci c'est un
fan du ch a choisi un enfant est
justement cette image c'est aussi un
moyen de se différencier de candidats
qui paraît le plus agressif et là vous
allez voir une autre candidat qui elle
aussi se radicalisent dans sa façon de
présenter les choses c'est ali delgo qui
est très différente ll a décidé par
exemple elle de jouer la carte offensive
dès le départ comme marine le pen à
l'attack ses adversaires elle dit il
nous faudra écarter les adeptes du bruit
de la fureur les complaisants avec les
dictateurs effectivement forcément il
parle de de mélenchon le pen ou zemmour
à une petite référence à françois
mitterrand voilà exactement cette image
elle est très symbolique on voit une
anne hidalgo qui est très nostalgique au
départ elle grandit la rose du parti
socialiste et après voilà cette image de
françois mitterrand qui apparaît en 1981
donc forcément elle veut s'inspirer de
l'âge d'or du partitionnement
ressusciter la grande halle berry les
glorieuses socialiste pas sûr qu'elle
ait parviennent on verra ça ça compte
pas fait clip je ne sais pas mais ce qui
me frappe je me souviens en 2017 marine
le pen avait fait un clip près de
l'océan la tripe bretons
exactement et l'a visiblement elle
préfère le contact avec les gens à la
barre du navire c'est le fameux la
fameuse bibliothèque au ciri des livres
de goebbels notamment qui avait très
marqué les français avait même suscité
la polémique virginie visionner ce soir
on va parler de l'importance du rire
dans les campagnes présidentielles mais
oui l'importance de l'humour parce que
bon c'est la politique c'est du sérieux
on le voit de plus en plus la campagne
qu'on vit actuellement elle est plus que
sérieuse bien sûr on parle de la guerre
en ukraine on parle de la société de
tout ce qui brille a rien qui nous
prêtent à rire fin bref on a connu plus
lol 1 comme climat on va pas laisser
dire et c'est dommage en fait parce que
finalement l'humour ça peut être une
vraie arme électorale alors un exemple
cette semaine avec fabien roussel qui a
déclenché l'hilarité au congrès de la
fnsea quand il parlait des sangliers et
des glands on regarde tout de suite
avec les sangliers on a un problème de
gland et cause dit ça c'est que je suis
un peu expert en la matière il y en a
plein chez moi des sangliers des se voit
des glands
il est sur un nuage il est ultra des
temps il est détendu il a voilà ils sont
qui l'a dit le bon mot il reste dessus
déclenché l'hilarité allait l'arrêter
patrick timsit sors de ce corps donc ça
ça s'amuse celle là ça amuse ça marche
ça fonctionne très très bien autre
exemple c'est jean luc mélenchon le
tribun qui sait mettre tout le public
dans sa poche en parodiant une fable de
la fontaine on regarde également fait
confiance
à une tortue électorale ça gâche comme
moi
rien ne sert de courir
il faut partir à point et j'ai déjà et
puget quelques lieux un bras on vous en
fait plus rire l'humour ça permet de se
détendre cela permet de créer une
véritable complicité de paraphraser la
trentaine en disant tout sondeurs vite
aux dépens de celui qui l'écouté cette
leçon vaut bien une élection mal pas mal
tu es donc là le sens de l'humour on
voit que c'est très très précieux et
c'est même le philosophe bergson qui
nous dit ça il dit que le rire en fait
ça a quelque chose de profondément
humain le rire c'est humain le rire ça a
une signification et même une fonction
sociale et le rire et cérébrales parce
que le rire en fait exige une certaine
distance en dans quel sens précisément
alors en fait ça permet de montrer qu'on
sait faire francon ces pardons prendre
du recul qu'on sait rire de soi et
savoir rire de soi ce serait une preuve
d'intelligence je pense aussi aux cales
de marine le pen quand elle est
confrontée aux blagues de philippe
caverivière sur rtl elle arrive à rire
d'elle on regarde un extrait ça alors
marine on met des amoureux de shahi vous
un deux trois conseils entre amoureux de
chat déjà le cadre du rn et le militant
et comme le chat et il est fugueur alors
est-ce que vous avez essayé de remettre
des croquettes pour faire revenir
gilbert collard à nicolas bay
voilà alors que marine baron se moque de
ceux qui ont fui lé parti donc ça se
moque de ceux qui ont fait vrai qu'elle
adore elle adore ce genre de situation
marine le pen et c'est vrai qu'elle a
une forme d'auto dérision souvent est là
elle a l'air facile voire même le rire
au bord des larmes
faciles on se moque en effet des cadres
de son parti mais elle aurait pu le
prendre autrement il aurait pu ne pas en
rire et elle est un peu contrainte de le
faire en tout cas ça donne l'impression
qu'elle ne se force pas en effet comme
vous le dites et donc elle va rire des
propres déboires de son parti donc ça
signifierait qu'elle accepte d'ironie
qu'elle accepterait même peut-être la
caricature et ça peut la rendre
sympathique ça peut donner une forme de
complicité avec les gens qui sont autour
d'elle en plateau là sur rtl par exemple
ou bien avec le public en fait tout
simplement qu'il va d'écouté équivalent
à regarder donc finalement c'est bon
pour ça comme et c'est bon pour son
image donc le rire à cette importance là
aussi dans la communication politique et
c'est sans doute rire un peu naturel est
peut-être un peu francs qui lui donne
aussi peut-être une bonne passe
aujourd'hui actuellement dans les
sondages on verra ce que ça donne de
l'humaniser comme on le disait tout à
l'heure elle est devenue sympathique se
croyait à sa vraiment c'est un ressenti
plus sympathique dans sa dans son
expression publique depuis 2010 est de
ce point de vue là elle a beaucoup
changé mais petit je dirais petit ajout
à ce que vous vouliez dire je suis quand
même frappé qu'il ya deux candidats
auxquels on ne pense pas du tout quand
il s'agit d'humour c'est emmanuel macron
eric zemmour
de zemmour cela benz ans est mort comme
quoi si ils n'avaient pas entendu que
ses partisans appelé traité mâcon
d'assassins bas il aimait y mettait en
scène le procès de 20 le petit
dispositif il a mis en place pour avoir
des otaries but if the truth in en
matière d'auto
musée je pensais
dérision macro non plus on n aurait pas
encore ce que ça donne c'est le gros
gros meeting demain à la défense arena
40000 places on verra ce que ça donne
merci beaucoup c'est le week-end merci
infiniment bon voilà vos chroniques dans
le scan jusqu'au premier tour et même
jusqu'au 24 avril merci à vous riche à
la france contre elle-même c'est publié
chez grasset très bon week-end très
belle soirée et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]